اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي امانيال مكروه ان
بلاده ستعيد سفيرها من نيامي خلال ساعات
وانها ستسحب قواتها من النيجر بحلول نهايه
العامه وقد رحب المجلس العسكري الحاكم في
النيجر بهذا القرار واعتبره خطوه جديده
باتجاه السياده ولحظه تاريخيه تشهد على
تصميم النيجيريين كما دعا المواطنين
لمواصله النضال لتحقيق طموحات المستقبل
بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات قرار مكرون
سحب قوات بلاده من النيجر وانهاء وجودها
الدبلوماسي هناك كخاتمه للازمه بين قاده
الانقلاب وباريس بشان الوجود الفرنسي في
النيجر ما مدى تاثير الانسحاب الفرنسيه
على المشهد السياسي والميداني بالنيجر في
ضوء الترحيب الواسع الذي استقبل به قاده
الانقلاب قرار الانسحاب كيف سينعكس السحاب
باريس من النيجر على مستوى وحجم النفود
الفرنسي في افريقيا بعد سلسله انقلابات
شهدتها القاره في الفتره الاخيره
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو شهرين من الشد والجذب بين باريس
وسلطات الانقلاب في النيجر تخلت فرنسا عن
اصرارها على التمسك بما كانت تعتبره وجودا
شرعيا في النيجر لسفيرها وقواتها هناك
واعلن رئيسها ان السفير بلاده في يامي
سيعود الى باريس في الساعه القادمه وان
القوات الفرنسيه في النيجر ستنهي وجودها
هناك بحلول نهايه العام الجاري بين ان
مكروه الذي جدد موقف بلادها الذي يعتبر
الرئيس المنقلب عليه الشرعيه الوحيده في
النيجر اشار الى وجود ما سماها تصفيه
حسابات عرقيه قال انها شكلت جزءا من دوافع
الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد بازو
المجلس العسكري الحاكم في النيجر والذي
اعلن اغلاق المجال الجوي امام طائرات
الفرنسيه بادر بالترحيب باعتزام باريس سحب
سفيرها وقواتها من النيجر واعتبر ذلك خطوه
جديده باتجاه السياده ولحظه تاريخيه تشهد
على تصميم الشعب النيجيري وارادته بحسب
وصفه واضاف المجلس ان نضال الشعب اثمر وان
كل من يهدد مصالح النيجر سيغادره شاء ام
اباه كما دعا المجلس مواطني في بيان بهذه
المناسبه الى مواصله ما وصفه بالنضال
لتحقيق طموحات المستقبل بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من النواكشه
الدكتور سيد عمر شيخنا مدير المركز
الاقليمي للابحاثي والاستشارات والخبير في
الشان الافريقي ومن جنابه الدكتور حسني
عبيدي واستاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
جنيف ابدا معك دكتور حسني دكتور حسني يعني
فرنسا ما كانت تعتبره قبل فتره زمنيه
قريبه بانها قرارات غير شرعيه صادره من
جهه غير شرعيه تقوم اليوم بتنفيذ هذه
القرارات بسحب قواتها وسفيرها من النيجر
ما الذي تبدل بين الامس واليوم
لانه فرنسا وصلت الى طريق مسدود وخاصه
الرئيس ماكرون من الصعب جدا لابقاء على
هذه المعركه يعني معركه عرض العضلات ما
بين الرئيس ماكرون وبين القوات الانقلابيه
فرنسا رات وصلت الى قناعه مفادها بان قوات
الاكواس ليست جاهزه هناك تردد كبير هناك
خشه وان في النهايه التداعيات العمل
العسكري سواء كان من قبل الاكواز بدعم
فرنسي او من جهه اخرى ستكون لديه نتائج
وخيمه على النيجر وعلى المنطقه هناك نقطه
ثانيه اعتقد انه فرنسا وجدت ان موقفها
الذي كان فعلا موقف الدغماتي كان موقف
حادا كثيرا لم يترك اي فرصه للتفاوض منذ
البدايه في النهايه اصبحت فرنسا معزوله
حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدات
بتسويه بتفاهمات مع مع النيجر وابقت على
قوه قواتها في شمال النيجر ثم دخول
الجزائر على الوساطه وتوجه وزير خارجيتها
ورفضها كذلك للتدخل العسكري واخيرا
الانقلاب انقلاب على بونجو ولم تحرك فرنسا
اي شيء بالاضافه كل هذه العوامل في
النهايه اقنعت الرئيس الفرنسي بانه في
النهايه لا يمكن ان يربح هذه القضيه ومن
شانه ومن العكس من الاحسن ان يقوم باخراج
على القرار الذي اتخذ منذ فتره وهو خروج
القوات الفرنسيه وخروج السفير الى الاخراج
الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس ماكرون ربط هذه او
خروج قواته بان سلطات الانقلاب في فرنسا
لا تريد محاربه الارهاب كيف تنظر الى هذه
الاشاره
الرئيس الفرنسي كان مجبرا نظام الراي
العام الذي يعجز منه وكذلك جزء من الاحزاب
السياسيه كانت منذ البدايه ضد القرار
الفرنسي ضد هذا التعنت الفرنسي وكانت منذ
بدايه تقول بانه يجب الخروج الان لكن
الرئيس الفرنسي انا اعتقد ربما عول او كان
يراغن على تدخل عسكري ثم انه لا بد له من
اخراج اولا قال بان هذا الخروج تم
بالتشاور مع القياده الشرعيه وحتى ان يخفف
من وطئه هذا القرار الحاد ثم النقطه
الثانيه وهي قضيه الارهاب يجب ان نذكر بان
قوات عمليه بركان والدخول الى النيجر
النيجر ليست اي شيء هي نقطه الارتكاز
الاساسيه بالنسبه لفرنسا في منطقه الساحل
بانه يجب ربط ذلك بيع الارهاب وانا فرنسا
جاءت للنيجر بطلب من رئيس لمحاربه الارهاب
وبالتالي على النيجر ان يتحمل في النهايه
تبعات هذه المسؤوليه مسؤوليه الانسحاب
الفرنسي باعتبار ان فرنسا كما يقول او كما
تقول فرنسا كانت عنصرا اساسيا في محاربه
الارهاب في النيجر وفي منطقه الساحل طيب
دكتور سيد اعمل شيخنا
على ماذا كانت تراهن فرنسا سابقا في
الاشهر السابقه ولم يتحقق لها فاقدمت على
اتخاذ قرار بتنفيذ رغبات السلطات
الانقلابيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اعتقد ان فرنسا
وقعت تحت صدمه انقلاب النيجر هي لم تتوقع
حدوث هذا الانقلاب اصلا وعندما وقع
الانقلاب ارتبكت ووقعت تحت الصدمه كان
لديها فرصه هي العمل العسكري المباشر
بسرعه في اليوم الاول او الثاني على
الانقلاب في النيابه بتنسيق افريقيا ولكن
هذا لم يحدث وبالتالي حدثت متغيرات جديده
من الموقف الامريكي الساعي الى وراثه
الوجود الفرنسي والفاء الذي يفهم جيدا ان
هنالك مناخا كبيرا في غرب افريقيا معادي
لفرنسا وتريد امريكا لنفسها
عن عفوا الموقف الامريكي تميز عن الموقف
الفرنسي منذ ان اقام السلطات الانقلاب
بخطوتها فما الذي تغير اليوم
وهذا ما اردت الاشاره اليه ان الموقف
الامريكي ظل في خط موازي للموقف الفرنسي
خط اخر
مختلف تماما عن الخط الفرنسي وكان امريكا
تريد وراثه النفوذ الغربي في المنطقه على
حساب فرنسا فرنسا ايضا كانت تراهن على
الكواس وعلى خطه التدخل العسكري هذه ايضا
بدا ان هنالك مشاكل كبيره وان هنالك عواقب
وخيمه لهذا التدخل ايضا فرنسا لديها مصالح
ثقافيه واقتصاديه ريفات تستثمر فيديوهات
جورانيوم الان الشركات الفرنسيه حتى شركه
الطيران الخطوط الجويه الفرنسيه وهنالك
مصالح اقتصاديه اذا استمرت فرنسا في هذا
التصعيد مع السلطات العسكريه في النيابه
يمكن ان تخسر كل شيء وبالتالي يعتقد ان
ماكرون ايضا الذي ادار هذه العمليه باداره
ضعيفه وصل الى الحائط المسدود ولم يكن
امامه الا الانسحاب حتى لا تقع فرنسا في
خسائر
اكبر طيب دكتور حسني عبيدي انطلاقا من ما
ذكرت فيما يتعلق باكواس وموقف اكواس والان
الانسحاب الفرنسي وتلبيه مطالب السلطات
الانقلابيه ماذا يعني ذلك بالنسبه للرئيس
بازوم هل يعني ذلك ان صفحه الرئيس بازون
قد طويت بلا رجعه
بالنسبه لفرنسا يعني لم تطوى وانا اعتقد
انه فرنسا ستدخل في مفاوضات بطريقه مباشره
وغير مباشره مع مع السلطات الجديده في
النيجر يعني كيف يمكن سحب العتاد العسكري
للقوات العسكريه من العتاد الثقيل بدون
تعاون وبدون موافقه القوات المحليه اذا
فستكون هناك من المؤكد مفاوضات رغم ان
فرنسا ترفض الاعتراف بما تسميه بسلطه
العنبر الواقع اما بالنسبه للرئيس بزوم
فانا اعتقد انه ان عودته حتى في حال يعني
تدخل عسكري كان من الصعب جدا اعاده ما
تسميه الدول الاكواس بالمسار الدستوري قبل
كل شيء لان هناك جهه في الجيش جهه مهمه
وكبيره قطاع كبير رافض لعوده بازوم ثم
النقطه الثانيه من الصعب جدا العوده الى
السلطه بدون ايجاد كذلك مخرج سواء
للانقلابيين او حتى للدول التي كانت ضد
هذا التدخل العسكري النقطه اعتقد نقطه
التفاوض ستكون خروج القوات العسكريه
الحفاظ على المصالح الفرنسيه في النيجر
خاصه الاقتصاديه والنقطه الاخيره ستكون
كذلك اعطاء ضمانات من اجل سلامه الرئيس
محمد الى خيارات فرنسا في الحفاظ على
مصالحها في افريقيا ولكن اسمع من الدكتور
سيد أعمر شيخنا يعني ماذا عن الرئيس بازون
ما هو مصير الرئيس بازوم بعد الموقف
الفرنسي
الرئيس بازون اصلا كان في موقف ضعيف فهو
ينتمي الى
اقليه عربيه بل تحت وضع الاقليه ثم ايضا
جاء الى السلطه بدعم من محمد يوسف وكانه
يلعب دور المحلل الاجتماعي ياخذ السلطه
برهه من الزمن حتى يعود او ابنه وبالتالي
وضعه كان مهزوزا وحتى
مناخ الانقلابات الذي حدث مالي وفي
بوركينا فاسو وكان من الواضح ان النيجر
ستكون هي الخطوه المواليه وهنالك صراع
دولي امريكا موقفها الاخير قبل اسابيع
عبرت عنها تريد عوده الديمقراطيه الى
النيجر عوده الديمقراطيه اي استئناف
المسار الدستوري الديمقراطي ولكن بدون
محمد
وبالتالي فرنسا ستفاوض من اجل سلامه
الرئيس محمد بازون وهذا هو اكبر شيء ممكن
ان تحققه بالاضافه الى الحفاظ على مصالح
الاقتصاديه والثقافيه في النيجر دكتور
حسني طيب هذه الخطوه الفرنسيه ما الذي
تمثله بالنسبه السلطات الانقلابيه وصفت
باللحظه التاريخيه ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني من المؤكده انها يعني تصور من قبل
الانقلابين وحتى من قبل العديد من
النيجيريين بانه انتصار للسلطه الجديده في
النيجر وانه فشل كبير لكن اكثر من العلاقه
فقط ما بين ما بين السلطات ليبيا في
النيجر والرئيس يعني خساره كبيره يعني هذا
التراجع ويعتبر تراجع يشكل لانعطاف في
السياسه الافريقيه لفرنسا لان فرنسا كانت
تعول كثيرا على النيجر ليس فقط بحكم
موقعها الجغرافي ما يسمى منطقه الثلاث
حدود ثم كذلك لانها جاءت بعد انقلاب
انقلابين في بوركينا فاسو وكذلك في في
مالي ثم كذلك
للاستثمارات الاقتصاديه المهمه والرساله
يعني في النهايه هذا التراجع الفرنسي
الكبير من منطقه النيجر وفشلها امام
الانقلابين هو رساله يعني في النهايه سيئه
بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه ان التعويل على
فرنسا يعني لا يمكن المراه لانه لا يمكن
المراهنه كثيرا على الموقف الفرنسي حتى
الولايات المتحده تعتقد في النهايه بانه
ترك نعم يعني فيما يتعلق بالنفوذ الفرنسيه
سنعود اليه ولكن فيما يتعلق بكيفيه تعاطي
السلطات الانقلابيه بعد هذا القرار هل
ستتعنت اكثر في مفاوضاتها مع اكواس على
سبيل المثال
هي تعتبر نفسها منتصره الان الموقف يعني
موقف سيتغير مع التغير الموقف الفرنسي
لانه من الصعب جدا على اكواس القيام
بعمليه عسكريه بدون تغطيه جويه بدون اسناد
من قبل القوات الفرنسيه هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه واصلا الموقف كان ضعيف
يعني كان موقف مترددا وبالتالي فستلتزم
كذلك بموقف مفاده بانها ترحب باي وساطه
انها تقبل الوساطه الدوليه وكذلك بعوده
عوده عمل المؤسسات الديمقراطيه لكن لا لا
اعتقد ان الايكوس بدون فرنسا يمكن ان تقوم
بعمل ريادي من اجل اعاده الرئيس محمد
الرئيس محمد بازون دكتور سيد عمل شيخنا هل
سيتبدل الموقف موقف اكواس على وقع الموقف
الفرنسي
اصلا كان موقف ضعيف لانها فشلت في التعاطي
مع القضيه في مالي ومع الانقلاب في
بوركينا فاسو وبالتالي كان نشازا موقفها
في النيجر هي كانت تريد ان تكون منظمه
اقليميه تدافع عن الديمقراطيه وعن الشرعيه
الدستوريه وتريد ايقاف عدوى الانقلابات
وانها اذا لم تتصرف في مواجهه الانقلابين
في النيجر فان هذه الموجه ستمتد لتشمل
بلدان اخرى ولكن لا يمكن ان تتصرف الى
بدعم فرنسي او دعم دولي بدا ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديها موقف خاص قوى
اقليميه كبيره مثل الجزائر لديها موقف حتى
تشاد لديها موقف اخر مضاد لموضوع التدخل
العسكري في النيجر اذا الاكواس الدول
المتحمسه فهي السنغال وساحل العاج وبنيني
الى مستوى ماء وهذه الدول غير قادره
للتدخل وحتى نيجيريا التي راس الحربه في
حاله تدخل عسكري واجهه موقفا العلماء ومن
المجتمعات المدني ومن مجلس الشيوخ
وبالتالي وجهه معارضه داخليه قويه
الدكتور حسني كيف يمكن ان يمنعكس الوضع
الان مع انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه على
محاربه الارهاب خاصه ان الرئيس ماكرون
غمزه من هذه القناه
يعني هذه القضيه شائكه لانه بالنسبه لنيجر
الجديده تقول بان فرنسا في النهايه لم تقم
باي عمل اضافي او القيمه المضافه لفرنسا
في محاربه الارهاب في النهايه لم تكن
واضحه بالعكس ان العمليات الارهابيه
الارهابيه زادت لكن نحن نعلم جيدا بان
قوات النيجر هي تعاني كذلك من مشاكل كبيره
في العتاد وكذلك مشاكل كبيره في التدريب
وبالتالي وجود قوات اجنبيه مفروضا يكون
اسنادا مهما لمحاربه الارهاب خاصه وان
الدوله مثل النيجرى قوات عسكريه في النيجر
متواضعه جدا او حتى دول الجوار لا يمكن
لها بدون ان تكون هناك جهد دولي وتعاون ان
تحارب الارهاب لكن المقاربه الجديده التي
ربما يحذر لها القاده الجدد وهو انه
محاربه ارهاب هي مقاربه شامله وانه لابد
من الحوار في النهايه ربما مع بعض فصائل
هذه التنظيمات وانه لابد ان تتغير الحرب
ضد الارهاب لانه كل ما قامت به فرنسا
مدعومه سواء من قوات اوروبيه او حتى من
قوات امميه لم تؤدي الى نتيجه ايجابيه لكن
الاخطر من ذلك اعتقد اخطر من ذلك ان
الرساله هو انه يمكن ان تقوم بانقلاع
ويمكن ان تقوم بانقلاب داخل في دوله
افريقيه حتى بتواجد قوات امريكيه وقوات
فرنسيه وانا اعتقد ان هذه الرساله التي
هذه الصوره التي كانت لا ترغب فيها فرنسا
لكن للاسف وقعت فيها وانه تواجدها لم يمنع
وقوع انقلاب مضاد لمصالح ولكن ذلك حدث في
دول اخرى افريقيا ايضا دكتور حسني الدكتور
سيد اعمل شيخنا
اشار الدكتور حسني عبيدي الى ضروره وجود
قوات اجنبيه مسانده في محاربه الارهاب
داخل هذه الدول بالتالي هل يمكن استبدال
القوات الفرنسيه بقوات روسيه او بجماعات
مسلحه تتبع لروسيا شاهدنا الاعلام الروسيه
ترفع داخل النيجر من قبل المواطنين
المطالبين بانسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
سيدتي المقاربه التي تنتهج القوى
الانقلابيه الجديده في مالي وبوركينا فاسو
ونيجر لمواجهه الارهاب هي مقاربه خاطئه لا
يمكن استبدال الوجود العسكري الفرنسي
التقليدي بوجود عسكري او لقوات روسيه
مباشره هذا لا يحل الاشكال الاشكال يتعلق
بضعف الدوله في هذه البلدان هذه البلدان
تعاني من الهشاشه المؤسسيه ضعف المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه اوضاع اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
وحاله انقسام مجتمعي اذا اخذنا مالي
نموذجا وهي التي ام دول الساحه التي تعاني
من اكبر المشاكل مشكله ازوات هذا يتعلق
بجلوس الماليين للتفاوض لحكم ذات موسع
للاصواديين يحفظ لمالي وحدتها ويحفظ نوع
من الاستقلال هذه هي القضايا الاساسيه
التي لا تريد مثلا المالي ان تواجهها هذه
لا ينفع فيها فاقنر ولا ينفذ فيها وجود
فرنسي ولا وجود لانها قضايا عميقه تتعلق
ببنيه الدوله تتعلق بعقد اجتماعي يربط
مكونات هذا البلد نفس الشيء في بوركينا
وحتى في النيجر هذه مشكله ينبغي مراجعتها
لان موضوع المدخل الديمقراطي يعني نظريا
ما تقوله هو الصحيح ولكن على الارض ما
احتمالات ان يكون هنالك فراغا امنيا تقوم
روسيا بسده
الان اعلن عن تعاون بين الدول الثلاث مالي
وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر وتم الاعلان عن هذا
الاتفاق في ظل وجود نائب وزير الدفاع
الروسي هذه اشاره الى ان روسيا تقوم بسد
الفراغ الفرنسي ولكن هل هذا سيكفي لمواجهه
الارهاب الاسبوع الماضي سقطت خمس طائرات
للجيش المالي في منطقه مالي في منطقه
ازواد ازواده من الطوارق ومنها حتى الفلان
من الحركه الوطنيه لتحرير الضواد والعربيه
وحتى ملاك الارض وحتى الفلان الجميع ينخرط
في ديناميه عسكريه لمواجهه الدوله الماليه
هذا مشكل داخلي كبير ولا يعتقد ان روسيا
لديها
قدوه في اداره التنوع البشري والاجتماعي
داخل الدوله ولا نموذج ديمقراطي يمكن ان
يستوعب ولا حتى القوه فرنسا من 2013 تتدخل
بمختلف انواع الاسلحه وهي مدعومه اوروبيا
ومع هذا الارهاب اليوم وصل الى مستويات
عاليه وغير مسبوقه على مستوى التنسيق وعلى
نوعيه العمل العسكري وبشكال الاكبر
دكتور سيد عمر هنا اتوجه للدكتور حسني
عبيد الدكتور حسني الرئيس ماكرون غمزه من
قناه محاوله تصفيه عرقيه هي ما ادت الى ما
انتهى اليه الوضع في النيجر كيف تقراون
هذه الاشاره
انا اعتقد ان التفاته غير موفقه من قبل
يعني رئيس دوله ديمقراطيه لانه يعني حاول
حاول الشعب في النيجر وحتى العديد من
الدول الافريقيه تجاوز هذه النعرات وتجاوز
ما بالانتقال
الانتماءات القبليه والانتماءات الجهويه
او العرقيه وبالتالي حصر اعتقد ما وقع
الانقلاب التغيير لانه انقلاب ضد عرقيه
اعتقد لا يخدم لاستقرار في مالي وفي
النهايه لا يصلح العطب الذي اصاب سياسه
الخارجيه في افريقيا
دكتور سعد
مالي سؤال الان النيجر ما الذي بقي لفرنسا
داخل القاره الافريقيه
ما جرى في النيجر وفي هذه الدول هو خساره
حقيقيه للوجود العسكري والسياسي
والاقتصادي والاستراتيجي لفرنسا عندما
استقلت البلدان الافريقيه كانت هذه نهايه
للامبراطوريه الاستعماريه الفرنسيه ايضا
خساره هذه البلدان على النحو الحالي هي
خساره لما تبقى من نفوذ فرنسي في منطقه
الساحل ومع هذا لا زالت هنالك دول تمثل
نقاط ارتكاز لفرنسا مثل السنغال وساحل
العاج وحتى الجابون وبنين والتوغو ولكن
ايضا خساره ماريو نيجر خساره كبيره ولا
تعوض ولا سيما في الموقف من مكافحه
الارهاب وايضا
اليورانيوم والثروات الاستراتيجيه والاهم
وجود لاعبين دوليين يدخلون المنطقه على
حساب فرنسا وعلى انقاض النفوذ الفرنسي
الدكتور حسني ما هي خيارات فرنسا الان
للحفاظ على مصالحها في القاره الافريقيه
في ظل وجود نفوذ اجنبي اخر كما ذكر
الدكتور سيد عمر وايضا في ظل انسحابها من
العديد من الدول الافريقيه
الموقف الايجابي كان في مع النيجر وفي
افريقيا كان ثمنه عدم عدم فتح المجال
لروسيا وانا اعتقد انه ليس في مصلحه سواء
نيجره والدول الاخرى دول الساحه ان تساهل
وان تفتح المجال اكثر مما هو عليه الان
بالنسبه
العسكر الثاني النقطه الثانيه العسكر يعني
بالطبيعه واعتقد انه مصلحتهم فتح كذلك
يعني تعاون جديد مع فرنسا يعلمون جيدا بان
فرنسا لها دور مهم جدا معتبر في اوروبا
والمقاربه مقاربه التنميه الشامله تحتاج
الى تمويل هذا التمويل لا يمكن ان ياتي لا
من روسيا ولا من الصين ولا اعتقد انه
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده كذلك
المنتديات الدوليه يمكن ان تساعد اذا كان
هناك فعلا برنامج تنموي تنموي شامل
وبالتالي الجيش مطالب في النيجر وانا
اعتقد هو بدا اصلا التفاوض بان كيف يفتح
الباب بالتفاوض خاصه مع القيادات العسكريه
للانسحاب وبعد ذلك بناء على هذا التعاون
التقني بناء عليه علاقه جديده مع فرنسا
امر في اقل من دقيقه ما هي الدروس
الفرنسيه المستقاه بعد تجربه النيجر
اعتقد ان فرنسا ستراجع سياساتها لمنطقه
الساحل وينبغي ان تركز على موضوع
الديمقراطيه والمجتمع المدني بشكل صادق
وايضا تراجع موقف
الاملاء على الدول الافريقيه وان تستمع
وان تقرا جيدا ما يجري في هذه الساحه وان
تكون محاربتها للارهاب محاربه موضوعيه
لانها قامت في مالي عشر سنوات ولم تنجح في
حل مشاكل كان بامكانها ان تنجح فيها في ظل
وجودها العسكري والاستراتيجي الكبير شكرا
لك الدكتور سيد أعمر شيخنا مدير المركز
الاقليمي للابحاث والاستشارات والخبير في
الشان الافريقي كنت معنا من نواكشوط
والشكر موصول للدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جنيف من جنيف
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]